à autant cette fois les pompiers sont
intervenus dans un logement ou une
fillette de 5 ans avait été laissé seul
alors qu'elle était sous la garde de son
père reste à savoir pourquoi et à
éclaircir les circonstances
la gendarmerie a ouvert une enquête les
précisions de françois latour ce
mercredi matin à 9 heures les pompiers
interviennent place d'allan cours à
autun c'est le voisinage qui se
plaignait d'un chien qui aboyait depuis
plusieurs jours les ponts qui décide
d'entrer dans le logement sur motif de
non réponse aux appels
là ils vont découvrir une fillette de 5
ans devant l'état d'insalubrité du
logement la fille est en bonne santé et
emmené à l'hôpital d'autun pour des
examens
la gendarmerie a ouvert une enquête elle
était sous la garde de son père dans le
cadre d'une séparation difficile
d'après les différentes constatations
recueillis par la gendarmerie le père se
serait absenté que quelques heures pour
des courses la mairie d'autun quant à
elle a décidé de lancer une procédure
pour logements insalubres le maire
vincent chauvet meilhan confié que le
logement était impropre à l'habitation